[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ilut un âge d'or du transport
ferroviaire qui ressemble à un lointin
souvenir
d'enfance dans ce monde d'avant les
trains partaient et arriv à l'heure et
surtout ils allaient dans les
villages
ces photos on témoigne il y une époque
où les trains sont arrivés en gare à
marsillango à nain surbevvron à la fertb
AR cette carte des années 30 conservée
par cet amoureux du chemin de fer nous
rappelle que le réseau a autrefois été
beaucoup plus développé qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui dans les années 30 on est au
maximum quasiment la poogée du réseau
ferroviaire français c'est 1920 avec
cette notion du réseau fressiné qui
voulait que chaque sous-préfecture soit
reliée à sa préfecture et à
Paris l'essentiel du réseau a été
développé par des sociétés privées avant
la création de la Société Nationale des
chemin de fer par le Front populaire en
1938 à ce moment-là des petites lignes
trop peu fréquentées ont déjà été fermé
mais c'est plus tard après guerre que la
situation s'est encore
dégradée au fur et à mesure de de la de
la comment dire du développement
automobile et du développement des des
camions les les lignes fretes ou les
ligne voyageur ont été petit à petit
réduites aussi et dans un dans une
approche qui a été une approche je
dirais du du jardinier avec son sécateur
mais à force de couper c'est aussi quand
même les les petites lignes qui font les
grandes lignes et ben on a quand
même réduit l'attraction du l'attraction
du
[Musique]
ferroviaire au fil des coupes franches
le réseau ferroviaire français a changé
de visage par rapport à la période faste
de
1925 les seules branches qui repoussent
sont celles des arbres qui encombrent
les voies à château ne sur Loire le
dernier train de voyageur est passé dans
les années 40 mais depuis près de 20 ans
association se bat pour la réouverture
d'une ligne qui relierait la ville à
Orléan d'un côté àen et montargie de
l'autre donc là cette gare là on pourra
pas l'utiliser alors non non non en fait
là il y a un projet du coup de faire
un une salle de convivialité et du coup
c'est pour ça en fait on avait on avait
regardé pour être sûr que ce projet là
vienne pas entacher la la possibilité de
réouverture de la ligne alors où est-ce
qu'on mettrait la gare alors bah en fait
il y a plus de gare en fait il aura plus
de gare physique il aurait plus de Lie
ça sera ce serait un point après av voir
où est-ce que ça
serait pour moi c'est un projet
d'intérêt général je ve dire on est sur
quelque chose d'indispensable pour
permettre au castelnevien d'accéder
derrière à à Orléan et à toutes les
infrastructure qu'on a au niveau dans
les toutes les études ont été faites
depuis que je crois qu'on est à des
chiffres assez énorme en terme d'étude
il y a beaucoup d'études qui ont été
faites il y a 10 ans il y a 15 ans ce
que je veux vous dire c'est notre
détermination nous avons pris la
responsabilité en région de conduire une
étude ce qu'on appelle une étude de
faisabilité dans un an nous pourrons
faire avec l'ensemble des instances
concernées par cela un tour de table
pour voir comment mobiliser les
financements en 2008 François bonau déjà
président du conseil régional
s'engageait sur une réouverture
prochaine de la ligne quelques années
plus tard en 2019 tout semblait prêt
mais le projet a déraillé en raison du
problème technique posé par les passages
à niveau de l'opposition politique de
quelques villes traversé par les voies
et d'un membre de financement mais
aujourd'hui l'espoir Rena venu présenter
le nouveau contrat de plan état région
qui prévoit un investissement de 373
millions d'euros dans le secteur
ferroviaire le ministre des Transports
de l'époque a reconnu l'intérêt d'une
réouverturech9 c'était une demande très
forte qui relayé dans la discussion le
président bonau est beaucoup d'élus on
revient à ce projet qui est remis à
l'étude alors vous me direz l'étude
c'est quoi c'est pas très concret si ça
va être vraiment des études rapides
sérieuses pour que ce projet qui est
attendu qui est important qui avait été
un peu mis de côté revoie le jour et il
est au cœur de ce contrat aussi après
des années d'une politique ferroviaire
essentiellement consacrée au
développement du TGV l'état redécouvre
les trains du quotidien et des
campagnes il y a quelques années
pourtant ils étaient dénoncés comme une
char pesantop lour sur le Buet
deétattion il y a maintenant 7 8 ans il
y a eu toute une réflexion sur justement
un moment donné le réseau ferroviaire
revient cher revient cher à l'État
revient cher et donc est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on garde tout ce qu'on a ou est-ce
qu'à un moment donné on se concentre sur
là où passe la majorité des trampes donc
il y a eu plusieurs grands experts nommé
par l'État pour réfléchir sur ce sujet
il y en avait eu un premier qui a dit il
faut tout arrêter et puis les G on dit
mais non c'est pas possible nous on en a
besoin exemple d'une ligne que l'État et
la SNCF avaient abandonné tourloche
sauvé
inextrémist par l'investissement du
conseil
régional l'état nous a dit SNCF réseau
son bras armé qui est nous ont dit d'ici
en 2018 d'ici 2020 2 22 23
elles arrivent à obsol il y a il y aura
ce qu'ils appellent des limitation
temporaire de vitesse c'est-à-dire le
train roule à 40 kmh donc ben ça veut
dire que la ligne elle est absolument
plus performante et globalement à terme
ferme donc on a négocié avec l'État
comme
toujours donc on a dit nous on est prêt
à mettre 50 % du du des
travaux après 10 mois de fermeture pour
travaux qui ont coûter à la région 36
million d'euros la ligne tourloche a
rouvert en
2022 six allersretours quotidiens sont
assurés pour desservir cette zone rurale
du Sud de la
Touren c'est vrai que c'est un gros
avantage pour nous parce qu'on est sur
une petite commune il y a des gens qui
ont pas de moyen de locomotion et c'est
vrai qu'elle est très intéressante moi
je je croise beaucoup de monde ou le
matin ou l'après-midi ou des fois le
matin et l'après-midi donc c'est bien
pratique le but ici n'est pas le
bénéfice ou la rentabilité car sur une
ligne comme tourloche l'usager ne paye
que 10 % du coout réel du billet le
reste est en financé par la Région en
plus de l'effort fait pour sauver
plusieurs petites lignes comme celle-ci
le conseil régional a dû aussi en raison
des lois de décentralisation récupérer
la gestion de plusieurs grandes lignes
sur lesquelles circulaient de vieilles
rames corill qu'il a fallu remplacé pour
un coût de plusieurs centaines de
millions
d'euros ces lignes on les a prises alors
je si j'étais un peu taquin je dirais un
peu en dshérance c'était des rames qui
aujourd'hui à au bout de 40 ans qui
était très difficile à maintenir la
maintenance c'était compliqué et on a eu
il y a quelques temps des des
locomotives qui brûlent en pleine voie
parce qu'elles arrivaient à la fin de
leur vie et il fallait les changer c'est
une bonne chose de
changer les nouvelles rames mises en
circulation on é P par la région et sont
exploit par
l'entreprisecf voyageur pour ce qui est
du réseau l'État reste propriétaire et
en confie l'entretien à l'entreprise
SNCF
réseauute d'investissement pendant des
décennies là aussi de gros travaux sont
en cours le remplacement des vieux
poteau catire é de 90 ans est un
chantier financé par l'argent public
mais réalisé pour l'essentiel par les
prestataires
privés
la règle en général c'est plutôt c'est
c'est 20 % qui reste chez nous et 80 %
qui est contractualisé avec des
entreprises extérieures voilà c'est un
peu la moyenne on va dire ce qu'on dit
c'est que 100 € investi chez SNCF réseau
c'est 80 € qui reviennent à l'économie
française parce qu'en plus on est sur je
crois 99 % de d'entreprise française
c'est pas des emplois délocalisables
donc c'est bon pour pour l'économie et
l'industrie française de faire des
travaux sur le
réseau les sociétés privées
entretiennent un réseau géré par l'état
où circulent des trains financés par les
régions ce sont les ramifications
complexes du système ferroviaire mis en
place sous l'influence des politiques
européennes pour les citoyens il est
devenu difficile de comprendre qui fait
quoi et pour l'usager pas simple de s'y
retrouver dans les offres merci pour
votre vIIL ça devient illisible ajouter
le fait que hé c'est l'inconvénient que
la régionalisation fait que on commence
à avoir des politiques extrêmement
différentes selon toutes les régions et
du coup bah vous avez une carte avec des
avantages dans une région mais dès que
vous sortez de la région vous n'avez
plus de carte vous navez plus d'avantage
donc la carte nationale n'est pas
valable dans les régions et
réciproquement donc donc ça ça devient
vraiment compliqué la SNCF entreprise
publique qui assure le même service sur
l'ensemble du territoire c'était avant
il reste aujourd'hui une holding financé
par l'État et gérant plusieurs filiales
de droits privé mais à capitaux public
parmi ell SNCF réseau pour les
infrastructures SNCF gare et connexion
SNCF voyageur pour l'exploitation des
trains un découpage décidé pour préparer
l'arrivée de la concurrence mais qui
reste contesté en interne par les
syndicats de
cheminau les cheminau se sent
appartenant à
laasncf d'ailleurs entre nous on dit
toujours la SNCF on dit pas SNCF
voyageurs SNCF
réseau le maillage du territoire et le
fait que les usagers partout en France
et en Navar puissent voyager selon leurs
besoins c'est un service public donc un
service public ça doit être géré par
l'État parce que sinon monsieur Fournier
en admettant qu'il y mette plus de
moyens que son homologue des pays de la
loi et alors quoi si vous êtes mé ou hor
les années vous n'aurez pas le même
service public ferroviaire c'est quand
même
dommage en centrreev de Loire région
métropolitaine la moins peuplée où 70000
voyageurs prennent le train tous les
jours les transports représentent
maintenant la moitié du budget du
Conseil
régional chaque année les besoins
augmentent et l'urgence climatique rend
plus nécessaire que jamais un
développement des transports publics
mais les ressources des régions restent
pour tenir les promesses de baisse
d'impôt de l'État les différents
gouvernements français ont fait le choix
de leur transférer des charges sans
transférer l'ensemble des
ressources les présidents de région
l'ont dit il faut un New Deal
ferroviaire faut qu'on mettre autant
d'argent qu'en Italie qu'en Allemagne
qu'en Espagne qu'en Angleterre
c'est-à-dire 10 fois plus faut pas on va
pas il faut 100 milliard sur 10 ans et
l'État investisent temp parce que nous
les régions on n'est pas Linder on n pas
de quasiment pas d'autonomie donc on
arrive au bout de de nos ressources
financières les Suisses investissent à
peu près 10 fois plus que nous par par
habitant même l'Allemagne l'Italie
beaucoup d'autres pays même le
Luxembourg encore plus investissent
massivement plus donc on a vraiment du
du retard à rattraper on subventionne
trop la route encore quand on décide
encore aujourd'hui d'élargir des
autoroutes l'élargissement d'une
autoroute sur 50 km c'est 600 millions
d'euros avec 600 millions d'euros en
ville on finance une une ligne de
tramoouis ou voire plus euh on finance
je sais pas moi une vingtaine ou une
trentaine de rames de de train une
électrification sur 300 400 km parce que
vous avez encore des lignes qui sont pas
électrifié donc là il faut qu'on change
un petit peu de
schéma si l'on considère les pays
voisins d'Europe de l'Ouest la France
est le pays qui a le moins investi dans
le ferroviaire depuis 20 ans mais dans
le le secteur des investissements
routiers elle fait en revanche partie
des premiers de la
classe on est attaché à la bagnole on
aime la bagnole et moi je
l'adore selon une étude commandée par
l'association Greenpeace la France a
depuis 1995 investi deux fois plus
d'argent sur les routes que sur le rail
ce qui la classe au 2e rang des pays
européens